[Música]
y en directo América llegó el momento de
hablar de economía por ello le doy la
bienvenida a mi compañera Daniela
Blandón Hola Andrés muy buenos días y
feliz inicio de semana feliz inicio de
semana también Daniela vamos a empezar
en Estados Unidos hoy inicia también una
semana clave para la economía de este
país porque Claro ya lo hemos venido
adelantando el presidente Se volverá a
reunir este lunes con Kevin mccarthy
quien es el líder republicano del
congreso para encontrar una salida a la
enquistada crisis por el techo de la
deuda será el tercer encuentro en menos
de un mes y a poco más de una semana que
venza el plazo límite para negociar y
evitar un posible default Marina sardina
nos tiene todos los detalles
una productiva llamada telefónica previa
a un acuerdo cara a cara el lunes el
presidente Joe biden y el presidente
republicano de la cámara de
representantes que Vilma carci se
sentarán a hablar con el fin de
desbloquear la crisis por el techo de la
deuda Walking
estoy viendo En dónde están nuestras
diferencias y Cómo podemos resolverlas
creo que esa parte ha sido productiva
pero no hay acuerdo seguimos separados
el mandatario por su parte estaría
dispuesto a recortar el gasto y hacer
ajustes Fiscales pero tachó de
inaceptables las propuestas de los
republicanos para subir el límite de
endeudamiento del país
Estados Unidos nunca ha incumplido nunca
ha incumplido nuestra deuda y nunca lo
hará
quien canceló su gira por Asia Pacífico
para resolver la crisis en su país
incluso tanteo la posibilidad de apelar
la sección cuarta de la décimo cuarta
enmienda de la Constitución la enmienda
dice que las deudas legalmente
adquiridas no pueden ser rechazadas o no
puede evitarse pagar Entonces el
presidente está entre la espada y la
pared y desacrata el congreso entra a un
proceso de impeachment Y por supuesto no
va a lograr nada en el senado Pero sería
el circo mayor del último año de el
pasado enero de Estados Unidos superó el
límite máximo de emisión de deuda
pública y desde entonces aplica medidas
extraordinarias para cumplir con las
obligaciones del tesoro por un tiempo
pero quedan menos de dos semanas para el
uno de junio cuando el tesoro podría
declararse incapaz de pagar las deudas
si ambas partes republicanos y
demócratas no llegan a un acuerdo
ahora Daniela Cuál es el ánimo de Wall
Street sobre estas negociaciones pues
para muchos
no es probable y mucho menos deseable
sin embargo los bancos y administradores
de activos de Wall Street se han estado
preparando para las consecuencias que
podrían ocurrir si fracasan estas
negociaciones es algo que no es nuevo ya
en septiembre de 2021 lo habían hecho se
habían preparado Pero esta vez la
diferencia es que el reloj está
corriendo y las posiciones siguen
estando muy distantes aumentando el
nerviosismo porque queda muy poco tiempo
para negociar la directora ejecutiva del
City grupo es James Fraser dijo que este
debate sobre el techo de la deuda es más
preocupante que los anteriores Y el
director ejecutivo de JP Morgan Jamie
Diamond reveló que el banco está
convocando reuniones semanales para
hablar sobre este tema
Simplemente sería catastrófico e
impredecible en sus consecuencias me
refiero a que en la economía se
sacudiría la confianza no habrá ningún
activo seguro y ciertamente disminuirá
el estatus del dólar como moneda de
reserva
vamos a cambiar de tema Dani nos vamos a
ir para Europa la matriz de Facebook
recibió una multa récord en Irlanda Pues
esta sanción dirigida a meta platforms
la impuso la comisión de protección de
datos de Irlanda que es en donde están
radicadas las tecnologías más
importantes de Europa principalmente de
Europa y de Estados Unidos y de muchos
otros países principalmente por temas de
impuestos la autoridad dijo que la
compañía infringió las normas de
protección de privacidad de sus usuarios
a través de su red social concretamente
ha venido almacenando procesando y
transfiriendo sus datos personales de
Europa a Estados Unidos este castigo
También incluye una orden para suspender
esa actividad en un plazo máximo de
cinco meses
la junta encontró que la infracción de
meta es muy grave ya que se trata de
transferencias que son sistemáticas
repetitivas y continuas Facebook tiene
millones de usuarios en Europa por lo
que el volumen de datos personales
transferidos es enorme la multa sin
precedentes es una fuerte señal para las
organizaciones de que las infracciones
graves tienen consecuencias de largo
alcance es importante mencionar Andrés
que esta es la multa más alta de este
tipo por protección de datos supere
Inclusive la de 746 millones de euros
que recibió Amazon en 2021 y meta dijo
que le parece injustificada y que va a
recurrir esta decisión que todavía le
faltan instancias vamos a ver entonces
cuál va a ser la resolución de todo este
este lío Daniela vamos a bangladesh está
sufriendo una crisis energética este
país pues además de los desastres
naturales que han afectado su economía
este país del sur de Asia está lidiando
por pagar el combustible importado del
cual depende ampliamente todo esto
debido a una fuerte escasez de dólares Y
es que sus reservas internacionales se
han reducido en más de un tercio desde
la invasión de Ucrania por parte de
Rusia para situarse en un mínimo de
siete años en poco más de 30 mil
millones de dólares por qué Porque sus
precios de Electricidad se han disparado
y también los precios de importación
tiene que poner más dólares para poder
importar esos combustibles la
consecuencia está experimentando
constantes cortes de Electricidad que
afectan a una de sus industrias estrella
que son las prendas de vestir las
grandes marcas occidentales fabrican sus
prendas en esta región debido a su mano
de obra barata y a las reglas muy laxas
sobre el tema laboral el ciclón mocha ya
había envíos había causado
cortes de energía e interrumpido la
producción en una época clave porque
estamos Andrés recordemos previos al
verano y Grandes multinacionales como
Walmart o Gap o el chanem Sara o
americangle outfitters entre otros pues
son algunos de sus mayores clientes nos
están viendo en aprietos para producir y
para exportar también por los altos
costos y todo lo que venimos hablando
eso se podría Traducir también en un
aumento de los precios de la ropa Claro
que sí porque recuerde que entre más
demanda haya menos oferta sube los
precios ley de económica
Daniela vamos a cambiar de tema
nuevamente esta vez vamos a hablar de
china que está reduciendo sus compras de
soya a Brasil en un 28% exactamente han
caído las importaciones chinas de soya
de Brasil hasta abril de este año el
principal comprador mundial de este
grano ha importado poco más de nueve
millones de toneladas desde Brasil que
de su mayor proveedor frente a más de 12
millones que había comprado en los
primeros cuatro meses de 2022 la razón
tiene que ver con retrasos en las
cosechas ahora la buena noticia es que
mientras china compra menos Estados
Unidos si está subiendo su demanda de
soya brasileña en un 20% este año y
vamos con nuestra cifra del día
rápidamente pues lo voy a invitar a ver
primero estas imágenes que vamos a
mostrar a continuación y las cifras son
los 380
piezas del ego que se necesitaron para
construir Este modelo Ferrari en tamaño
real la exposición se presentó el fin de
semana en Dinamarca en un parque de
diversiones dedicado al famoso juguete
este automóvil tardó casi un año en
construirse con la ayuda de los mismos
ingenieros de la compañía de automóviles
deportivos de lujo hoy es increíble todo
lo que se puede hacer con Lewis Bueno yo
soy fan de Lego tengo que decirlo
también porque pues bueno ya vimos como
en el Reino Unido hicieron
toda esta la ceremonia de coronación de
Carlos en LEGO Y también fue bastante
bonito Daniela hablando nuestra
directora económica gracias Nos vemos
entonces en unos minutos con más
información económica Así es acá nos
vemos